foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions that's the Ramsey show where
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George Campbell Ramsay
personality co-host of the smart money
happy hour is my co-host today open
phone to Triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five Paul is
with us in Minneapolis hey Paul welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks for taking the call I
have another should we pay off
the house early out of our retirement
question okay why is this one different
[Laughter]
um
words my wife and I are both retired
I'm 61 she's 58 we retired with the
mortgage
and
and I've got a number of differing
opinions from our financial guy I've Got
Friends that work in the finance
industry I worked for a bank in 30 years
and
um I guess just looking for another
opinion maybe one with a little bit more
Credence and some of the others I guess
okay so how much do you own your home
it's a 450 000 house we owe 170 and how
much do you have internet
what's that how much what's your net
worth what do you have in your nest egg
um net worth is about the million and a
quarter we've got uh just over a million
of that is uh investment in retirement
and if your house was paid off yeah if
your house was paid off why would you go
borrow on it
uh we would not well then what's the
difference
I I guess it just
let me rephrase the question maybe a
better question is if we decide to do
this
is it a process over multiple years to
ease a tax burden do we just bite the
bullet and
take the hit and do it once or
how how would I do it I've been doing
this 30 years I've never had anybody
call me back and say they were pissed
off because they paid off their house
fair enough
so one shot or would you uh I'd write a
check today I'd be debt-free I'd have
been debt free yesterday if I were you
and quit listening to all these idiots
there's a lot of idiots out there
running around with an opinion about
your money and you're a millionaire
what's your mortgage payment well don't
what's your mortgage payment right now
mortgage payment is what 1200 okay you'd
free up most of that which then now you
can invest so yes you'll lose some out
of that investment account but you're
going to still invest for the next 20
years
dude you're just gonna sleep so much
better tomorrow I mean we're both
retired so invest is rolling not
necessarily you have almost zero risk in
this situation because you could write a
check at any minute and pay it off if
you gotten a pinch you don't really need
the money in one way or the other it's
all about you know what is your end goal
when you're 85 do you want to have a
mortgage you know why would you keep it
there's no reason to keep it you
wouldn't go borrow on a paid for house
in order to have more money to invest
and so write a check and sleep better
tomorrow tonight pay it off tonight hit
the submit button and then when you go
and you get the mortgage release in the
mail make a copy of it take your shoes
off walk into the backyard have a
mortgage burning party and tell me that
didn't feel good
I mean there's just no there's just no
downside to this
um you know you're a millionaire you're
gonna you're gonna be okay either way if
you don't follow our advice if you
follow those idiots advice but if I've
got a financial person that's telling me
to stay in debt I'm getting a new
Financial person
period
because George we studied 10 167
millionaires the number of them that
told us that they became wealthy because
they borrowed on their home in order to
invest was precisely zero none of them
leveraged their personal residence to
build their wealth none of them and so
the idea that I continue to leverage my
personal residence in the name of
Building Wealth is an asinine based on
the millionaire data well we're seeing
so much more of this because people have
their record low mortgage rates they
don't want to let go of Dave yeah why
would I have my mortgage you know but I
got your mortgage rate B you know what
my mortgage rate is
zero I don't have one hello heck of a
race zero I got the best rate come on
man up and down you don't have to worry
about them because you don't need debt
anymore it's a great feeling
instead of worrying about what the
Market's doing so yes it hurts to write
that check and lose that much money lose
quote unquote but you never really had
it if you owed it to the lender in the
first place Paul pay it off son pay it
off you're there's a bunch of
intangibles that you're not even
considering in this decision you're
still acting like it's primitive math or
at least the idiots advising you are so
you're going to sleep different your
wife's gonna look at you like a hero
never never once have we had a wife said
you know my husband borrowed deeply on
our mortgage and he's my hero never came
up I love the Kermit Vibe she had too
there that's great how do I Miss Piggy
meets Kermit yeah well it's best it's
the best I can do uh Anna as with us or
is Anna or Anna it's Anna I'm sure and
she's in Grand Rapids is it Anna is that
right
yeah I'm Susanna hey how can I help
so I recently paid off all of my student
loans and I'm debt-free
yay way to go
thank you yeah so I I couldn't have done
it without you so
um but I have my three six months of
expenses I just finished that up and I'm
wondering now if I should be investing
my 15 or if I should be saving for a
wedding that my boyfriend and I are
planning to have in about a year and a
half so I'm wondering waiting for that
wedding yeah okay perfect
are you guys paying for this on your own
um we think so we don't really want it
like that's we just want to plan for
that and that if some something comes
then we'll go for it but yeah we kind of
just want to plan on doing it ourselves
just in case okay I would set a very
specific goal a number you're trying to
hit to save and I would try to hit that
before the year and a half is over and
then begin investing you got that money
set aside you know you're not gonna have
to go into debt for this wedding that is
the goal here and so that's why we're
telling you save for the wedding first
because what happens is you start
investing 15 the wedding was over budget
now we got to put it on a credit card
for sure yeah so what do you think
you're going to spend
um probably 25 is the goal we set okay
well if you yes that by the way that's
about an average wedding in America
right now so um you're not above average
you're not below average you're right
around there's 28 000 last year so the
um
the thing is having
um three grown kids that all got married
and I was involved in the budget because
I was paying for it
um or at least part of it anyway on one
all but one all of it but well anyway my
part the bride's part and then my son we
participated some have a detailed budget
not a general goal lay it out okay
there's how much we're gonna spend on
the photographer there's so much we get
on the dress there's so much we spent on
the reception and uh treat it I'm sorry
but treat it like a project you're
managing a project you are do you have a
timeline you have a budget and you you
know you stick to it what must be true
well we can't have that we got to have
this instead if you don't have a very
specific thing then you'll line item
you'll get into a mess there but that
sounds reasonable I would say for the
wedding first
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you three months free to
get started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow is
Catholic you can tailor the content
towards your faith tradition if you
don't have a faith tradition this is a
great place to learn more about it from
scripture readings and prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose p
remember Halo is giving you 90 days free
imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hallow.com
Ramsay today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five George camel will
be doing a live virtual training this
month to help you get clarity with your
money sometimes those are called
webinars I think so you're going to
learn more about margin in your finances
spend guilt-free make a budget for you
that works the next one's happening
September
26th at 12 30. Eastern 11 30 a.m Central
so it's a lunch deal George that's right
and I'm taking my lunch break to do this
so I would appreciate all of you joining
me we're going to actually walk through
very tactically what it looks like to
create margin in your every dollar
budget we'll show you how to set it up
how the paycheck planning tool Works
what to do what sacrifices to make to
spend less make more to get out of that
stressful money cycle free so to sign up
go to everydollar.com budgeting and
September 26th would be like this week
that's coming up that's like tomorrow
for most of you yeah so uh and you can
also get the replay a lot of people say
Dave I can't make it on my lunch break
sign up anyways we'll send you a link to
watch the replay still worth signing up
everydollar.com budgeting free webinar
free virtual training I like virtual
training yeah webinar doesn't ex I'm way
more exciting than webinar sounds very
geeky you deserve better than a virtual
training sounds very high tech I like
that I like it George it works man one
day we'll all be AI anyways so you'll
you'll still get the live version of me
today before the robots take over not me
not me you don't think AI could replace
you Dave it already has
you not seen it have you not seen that
no oh the Deep fake they can deep fake
your voice hilarious it's hilarious yeah
there's actually one guy that's running
a scam I've seen that on social media
social media they're gonna get what's
coming to him yeah I wouldn't mess with
Dave Ramsey I'm just saying well I'm
well we just had the lawyer call them
and explain it to him but yeah you know
so but they knew that they knew they
were scam guys so it's just but it's
like me giving advice and then they
change the voice poorly done audio voice
over it's not even AI I don't think I
think it's just a battle voice a bad
impression that's even more offensive
you'd almost rather have a robot screwed
up than a real person go I'm Dave Ramsey
yeah is that what it would sound like
kind of I do a terrible version of you
that was that was really bad I know I
don't have that Southern drawl all right
Pam's in Los Angeles hey Pam welcome to
the Ramsey Show
thank you for taking my call sure I am a
six I have a 66 year old Widow in good
health the only retirement I have is
property a home and a prop and land that
I own in Nolensville Tennessee it's
fully paid for
I generate
um
about nineteen thousand dollars a year
rental income
there's about two thousand dollars in
property taxes every year
is my Social Security
which is eighteen hundred and then I
rent out two rooms in the house that
I've been in California for eleven
hundred dollars a month
um
that together brings my income to about
fifty four thousand if I sell the
property I'll lose that twenty thousand
please don't sell and I don't know
what's it worth
probably six it was worth more before
the laws changed but it's worth say six
to seven hundred thousand okay
and uh the only kicker the other thing
that makes you a little tricky my son
and wife are looking to relocate either
the Huntsville or Nashville in the next
three to five years not not tricky at
all uh unless it's a family is a family
place or something
is it a family home place or
it was never a family home my husband
and I bought it and only lived there a
few months before we were transferred to
California okay do you have a property
management company running it okay so
you're making you're making 2.8 on your
money
okay
okay she doesn't charge that much but
okay no you're you're making nineteen
thousand dollars on six hundred thousand
right that's 2.8 percent
okay certifiably horrible
okay yeah so yes I think whoever told
you to sell it
um and sit down with a quality
investment advisor if you don't have one
click smart Fester at ramsesolutions.com
will help you find who we endorse in
your area to sit down and teach you what
you could put some of this money in but
if you made if you made five percent on
your money basically you would double
your money if you made ten percent on
your money you would quadruple your
money
and somewhere between five and ten is
what you should be making depending on
how much how much of you know what you
want to put it in in mutual funds so I'm
almost you know I'm 63 if I in my
situation meaning that the what I'm
comfortable with I would put in my case
a hundred percent of that in mutual
funds and my mutual funds have averaged
10 to 15 percent depending on the year
okay and so um and so I would be making
close to a hundred thousand dollars a
year where you're making 19.
but now that those mutual funds go up
and down in value more than that
property does but whoop-dee-doo you're
not making anything
so okay it must be raw land is it
no well it's five acres of raw land and
then a single family housed on it yeah
it's under rented severely smaller house
it's underrated severely yeah based on
its value
because uh but even then even then I I
you don't want a rental property in
nolansville Tennessee when you live in
Los Angeles so
I'm gonna sell that and put it in mutual
funds a good mix of which you could
determine after you learn a little bit
more about it but sit down with a good
investment advisor at a smart investor
if you don't have one they'll help you
do it they'll show you what to do but
teach you what you're doing and then you
can make that decision you may have some
taxes on this as well when you sell it
you need to set that aside but you will
have some taxes but depending on how
long you've had it sounds like you've
had it a long time so you may have
substantial capital gains but still
you're going to come out ahead
yeah you're just you can't
you're pinching every penny because
you're only making two percent of your
money yeah and a lot of people Dave are
fooling with real estate and then we ask
them hey what are you making on this
thing well 500 bucks a month a thousand
bucks a month I'm like 10 grand a year
that's not life-changing money
comparatively to if you just didn't fool
with the real estate and invested it
yeah and you could make returns that are
much greater than that yeah so that's
what we're talking about here if you're
going to go through the hospital real
estate I love real estate but you should
make more on it than the stock market's
paying so if the stock market's
averaging 10 to 12 percent you ought to
make more than that on your real estate
all things included I mean including the
value increases and other things but if
you're going to screw around with
renters and deal with you know air
conditioners braking and all that stuff
then you know you would want to make
more for the hassle Factor than you
would make just put in a mutual fund and
forget it
so especially long distance that's
always a nerve-wracking situation when
you're across the country there's
nothing in this property for you Pam
this sounds fun to me sounds like a good
thing to be out of Christina is in
Seattle Christina what's up
hi thank you guys so much for taking my
call on everything you guys do you too
how can we help
I'm calling in um my husband and I are
in baby step two and we're down to our
final bet which is 132 000 of student
loans with repayment coming back online
I've looked into some options to lower
my higher interest rate loans down and
I'm not sure if it's worth it to do the
refinancing
okay uh you get one shot if they're
Federal is it a lower interest rate
it is so out of my 132
000 100 000 of those are at six to seven
point five percent on a 15-year term
loan and I can refinance down to 5.5 on
a 10-year loan
is the best option that the lowest
option I know sure and then and then pay
it off in three or two or whatever yeah
yeah three three is the plan that we're
on right now okay three years to pay
everything off yeah a lower interest
rate helps so one percent's a thousand
dollars a year on 100 Grand right
okay that's what saves you
so a thousand dollars doesn't solve the
problem you being pissed off and getting
out of debt solves the problem but it
doesn't hurt yeah I'll take a thousand
to the good instead of a thousand of the
bad
okay the only place where my my we were
kind of is concerned is that it raises
the minimum payment of significantly and
you're raising the minimum payment
anyway you're getting out of debt paying
extra on it's going to do that yeah so
that's not a bad thing yeah yeah we're
not we're not keeping this thing around
like as a pet we're getting rid of it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Scott and Jenna are with us
hey guys how are you doing well thank
you hey George welcome good to have you
guys where do you live
Davenport Florida I just south of
Orlando oh yeah fun welcome to Nashville
and how much debt have you paid 94 000.
cool how long did that take 33 months
okay and your range of income during
that time 76 to 145. okay very cool good
very good so what kind of debt was the
94. it was our mortgage
yay love it love it congratulations
house and everything look at it weird
people that's right so what's this house
worth about 350. I love it and how much
in your nest egg in your retirement
about 95 000. excellent well done guys
yeah already a half a millionaires look
at you how old are you 36 33 well done
you guys good work incredible so what
started this journey uh 33 months ago
pay off the house and be weird I know it
kind of starts a little bit farther back
really when we first bought the house we
were pretty normal we got the 30-year
mortgage and
we knew about the Dave Ramsey principles
and the baby steps but we applied them
here and there kind of daveish and we
held on to the credit card and didn't
really make much progress on the
mortgage for the first several years as
could be expected and
um fast forward to 2020 we started
tuning in to the Ramsay show on podcast
and listening to the debt-free screams
really got us fired up to pay off our
mortgage and so we submitted to
refinance and get a lower interest rate
and start paying things off then we hit
a bump in the road coven hit we both got
furloughed oh so that delayed things a
little bit but August of 2020 just
several months later the refinance went
through and we were back in our jobs and
so that was kind of our kickoff moment
what really got things up to speed was
in January 2021 just a few months later
I got a new job as a result of an MBA
that I just finished and we started uh
coordinating Financial Peace University
at church and our class challenged us to
really walk the walk and so wow
the coordinator I know
every dollar and got our budget nice and
organized and focused and from then on
we were just laser focused on the
mortgage we had a couple promotions over
the next couple years that increased the
income so we incredible start giving but
the rest we maintained our lifestyle so
we had that margin to just keep
catapulting on the mortgage that's
incredible I love this the unexpected
blessing of coordinating an fbu class is
that it puts your butt into gear because
like I can't lead this class and not be
doing a budget and not be trying to hit
my financial goals exactly and you guys
did that without the lifestyle creep
even increasing your income yeah yeah
it's just as motivating to be
coordinating the class and to hear from
those who are taking the class as
participating as just you know someone
that signed up for it yeah way to go you
guys excellent excellent excellent work
so proud of y'all well done how's it
feel to not have a payment in the world
so good wow what's the first big thing
to do to celebrate so we actually just
did it a few months ago same month that
we submitted our our final payment we
went on a two-week vacation to Hawaii
yeah your anniversary as well there you
go good for you well done guys well done
now you got all the rest of your life to
do nothing but be generous and build
wealth exactly you're gonna be in a
great position absolutely amazing all
right tell folks what the key because
your coordinators now I mean your
coordinator is like a boss now right so
uh your coordinators uh what is the key
to getting out of that house and
everything when you're 36 years old
transitioning from the Excel spreadsheet
to
difference for us just to be able to see
every transaction come in this is an
unpaid commercial ladies and gentlemen
yeah I got it yeah that's great but to
see every transaction come in and be
able to update it in lifetime is really
helpful
um but then being on the same page with
our long-term goals because for us we
want to be able to meet needs as we see
them come in and so not having that
house payment not owing anybody really
frees up that income to do that
um but also I think just being content
with where you are and what you have
um not trying to keep up with the
Joneses as you go
um having that delayed gratification
and then really just like not
underestimating the small sacrifices and
the difference that those can make too
because it really helps you to build
that muscle of discipline as you look at
the bigger decisions that you have to
make and recently we heard it put that
there's no comfort in the growth Zone
and no growth in the comfort zone oh
no growth in the comfort zone no comfort
in the growth Zone yeah that's true
that's really where it happens that's
amazing well done you guys very very
very well done this is exciting what I
love about this what I'm realizing is
those in baby step seven who pay off
their house there's this natural letting
go of caring what other people think but
it's weird that when you're broke is
when you're trying to keep up and when
you have all these payments up to your
eyeballs and you let go of it and pay it
all off and you go why are we doing that
we got bigger goals in life why was I
worried about that guy yeah
now you're worried about who can we give
to this month I said who do we got to
impress this month that's a very
different life exactly I'm so proud of
you guys to figure it out that early
yeah it takes people their whole
lifetime to get that absolutely very
well done hey we've got the live and
give box for you that's the baby steps
and billionaires book that's the next
step in your journey for sure and The
Total Money Makeover book giveaway gets
somebody star started and since you're
coordinating a class we'll give you
another Financial Peace University
membership you'll find someone to give
that to I'm sure that needs it and
they'll be able to encourage them on
their Journey thanks for leading the
class we really appreciate it we really
enjoy it it makes a lot of difference to
have the class operating like you guys
especially when somebody's plugged in
like you guys are you know and
um and thanks for the advertisement for
the every dollar app that's good very
very good good stuff well done well done
Scott and Jenna Lakeland Florida area 94
000 paid off house and everything at 36
years old making 33 or did that in 33
months making 76 to 145 counted down
let's hear it debt free scream three
three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
all right way to go you guys that is so
fun
very good so proud of y'all good stuff
man so uh you're going to be doing an
every dollar uh virtual training or
webinar whatever webinar feels like
excel at least the virtual training
feels a little hipper like every dollar
you know it's not complicated if virtual
training makes it sound hard George will
not make it too hard to do I promise I'm
not that it's doing he's going to teach
you to do exactly what they're doing
find margin that's a word they use yeah
in your budget by using the every dollar
app and you got that's a free budgeting
seminar webinar whatever we're going to
call the thing and it's tomorrow for
most of you listening live that would be
the 26th of September and uh you get
that at everydollar.com budgeting it's
that simple and you're going to be doing
it you're gonna be teaching them the
same stuff that they learn yeah and
here's the thing I was like you guys I
thought budgeting was for Excel nerds
and accountants and I just realized oh
the point of the budget is to find
margin to spend less make more and hit
my financial goals not so that I can be
a super nerd and check a box off and I'm
I'm telling you opening Excel ruins my
day to this day so if you were that
person who has never budgeted because
you thought it was going to hurt your
brain I'm gonna make it so
mind-numbingly simple that you have no
excuse not to do it you're gonna go I
want that I want to show you how to go
from negative a thousand bucks a month
to positive a thousand to positive two
thousand to where you go there's nothing
I can't do now with that kind of margin
and that's what they did that's how they
got the help that's how you pay off the
house early folks it's that simple four
thousand in 33 months yeah that's it and
you got to pay for stinking House of 36
years old and you you and me when they
got a paid for house in your early 30s
we started the trend I guess but I love
seeing folks in their 20s and 30s doing
their baby step seven debt free screams
yeah and mind and this is the week
before the student loans start back um
so you know it feels like Jaws is
starting to Circle and you hear that
it's coming people make a plan you even
know what that is I just referenced a
movie that was before you were born I
was trying to connect with you oh you're
trying to thank you it's called
pandering yes I think it's not working
dang it
oh hey
my friends today and I was very
very
um I'm full of surprised this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45 five percent off that's
blinds.com rules and restrictions May
apply
foreign
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five our
question of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
they have local service providers to
repair maintain and improve your home
their network of experts offers top
quality work and customer service by
trained reliable service providers find
the help you need good company good
people at neighborly.com today's
question comes from Andrew in Minnesota
what are your thoughts on balance
transfer credit cards I have three
credit card debts I'm paying off in baby
step two and the interest rates are
really high would it be wise to transfer
it to a zero percent interest rate card
while I am paying them off
ah the life hack of the balance transfer
to the zero percent card
how many have built their wealth Dave no
I'm not a fan of these balance transfer
cards and one of many reasons is that it
doesn't solve the root problem you going
into debt another reason is the three to
five percent they charge you just to do
this which means if you transfer 10
grand you're paying an extra 500 bucks
for the pleasure of continuing to be in
debt
with a zero percent offer that will soon
run out while you're still in debt and
then we're back to square one
so
while I'm paying off debt can mean a lot
of things
while I'm paying off debt over 10 or 15
years which means you're not really
paying off debt or while I'm paying off
debt for one year because I'm gazelle
intense and sold everything but the kids
and they're worried you know I mean
that's that's two different things of
while I'm paying off debt so
um while I'm paying off debt over 10
years which means I'm not really doing
it then I'm moving with George don't
bother because you're just kidding
yourself that you actually did something
interest rates aren't your problem the
guy in your mirror is your problem you
need to quit spending like you're
freaking in Congress if you're instead
doing the other way and you're like
gazelle intense you're paying it off in
one year then what you're saving is 18
of your balance or 26 percent of your
balance minus whatever transfer fees
there are and so you would save some
money but let's just kind of talk this
through for a second let's say
let's say net of fees transfer that you
saved I'll make up a number let's say it
was a 20 and a five percent fee so net
of 15. you save 15 okay if you save 15
uh for one year on twenty thousand
dollars while you're paying it off well
you're not really saving it on twenty
thousand because during that year you
will have reduced it within six months
down to ten thousand so your average is
not twenty thousand your average is
about ten thousand that you're saving
the interest on does that make sense
okay this done math nerd here okay so
fifteen percent of ten thousand dollar
savings is fifteen hundred dollars on a
twenty thousand dollar balance
so is it worth it to say fifteen hundred
dollars on a twenty thousand dollar
balance in one year yes
but to George's Point does it solve your
problem no you have a twenty thousand
dollar problem you don't hit it with a
fifteen hundred dollar tool
you hit it with a twenty thousand dollar
tool which is you you be working you
butt off that's the tool yeah okay and
you be living on beans and rice rice and
beans and don't talk to me about you
deserve to go out to eat you'll be a
broke person in credit card debt you
don't get to go out to eat broke people
don't do that crap that's the other
pieces you have to actually change your
habits you can't just go up I switched
to the zero percent we're good now I can
keep living my life how I was living and
the problem is what I'm trying to point
out is the problem is when you make this
massive intellectual calorie burning
move right to make this transfer and I'm
beating the muscle genius ah I've got
the billion dollar credit card industry
on its back punching it in the nose no
you don't okay they are punching you in
the nose this is why we're having this
discussion so oh you're not gonna whip
their butt you they're the 800 pound
gorilla you might take a little chunk
out a 1500 chunk out but don't think
that that solves the problem it's okay
to do it as long as you know that 95 of
the problem still stands there and 95
percent of the solution still stands
there and that be you to your point yeah
so do the transfer if you want but don't
act like don't strut around act like you
did something and don't get comfortable
because now it's zero percent you're
going well it's fine and don't act like
you can do this odd infinitum because
that's what they're praying for that
they can keep haggling you hassling you
and punching you in the face and it's
time for you to uh just say you know
what I don't like the rules of this game
I refuse to play anymore I'm taking my
toys and going home you know I'm going
I'm getting away from you people you I'm
gonna put up a boundary you're talking
this is a toxic relationship absolutely
so what reminds me Dave I just uh we
uploaded this YouTube video on my
channel and reacting to this woman who
said hey velocity banking hack I paid
off my mortgage years early by maxing
out my credit cards and writing a check
to myself and then switching to the zero
percent cards one after another and all
of you should do this hack to pay off
your mortgage early it's genius and so I
broke it down on why velocity banking is
a scam but it reminded me of this
conversation about these balance
transfers so they renamed stupidity
velocity you have to give it a cool name
to keep it hip because then you know
infinite banking you've talked about
that I thought velocity means statement
speed that's the I don't know it's
stupidity yes but stupidity banking No
One's Gonna no they wouldn't sign up for
that no oh so we had to give it a
different name infinite banking Velocity
Bank oh it's it's stupid fast do stupid
fast quickly fast do do stupid quickly
uh you know how to sell things Dave you
know how that works goodness gracious
like winning a marketing narrative boys
and girls yeah
it's just exhausting so here's what
they'll jump through interest rates in
almost a thing to remember the reason
debt consolidation doesn't work in
general is that 88 of the people that
take out a debt consolidation loan end
up going deeper in debt because they
don't change the person in their mirror
the problem with this whole thing is
it's a pain in the butt because changing
you changing me me changing me is a pain
in the butt I don't like changing me I
like the old me I don't I don't want to
have to go through the pain of growth I
don't like it I don't like the
discomfort of transformation and yet
that's what makes a better version of me
and so changing me is the hook not
changing the um technique or the hack
so change the you know if you want to
shift your balances that's fine but you
still have 95 percent of the problem
you've only addressed five percent of
the problem so don't strut around the
yard throwing your shoulders back acting
like you be bad because you're not you
haven't done anything yet you just moved
it around the shell still has a pee
under it it's just a matter of which one
the con game on the street and you're
just playing the game you got you're
getting suckered again so it's there
somewhere you can count on it until you
get rid of the toxic relationship
completely by paying the stinking thing
completely off it's a big deal it's a
big deal so that's the difference in
see I grew up in the financial world as
a as an in the academic side of things
getting all the licenses and selling all
this crap and we are always taught that
the problem is a math problem
and it's just not when it comes to your
personal finance it's 80 Behavior 20 had
knowledge it's in the psych Department
yeah wrong Department it's not a math
issue it's a behavior if it's a behavior
problem then the solution is a behavior
modification
solution yeah people think well the
problem Dave is the 24 interest if I
could solve that no the problem is the
guy who got your who got themselves into
24 interest debt and if we can solve for
that we've solved for a whole lot more
than just this one little dinky debt oh
and let me tell you when you fall for
stuff like velocity
stupidity banking
um when you're desperate
or when you're greedy
if you want to con someone you need to
find people if you read I read a great
book by a con man one time he said if
you want to con someone find people that
are afraid or that are greedy
and if you so if you think that you're
the exception to the rule and you've got
the hack and you no one knows about it
but you
after all this time God selected you to
give him this one you've got to be
kidding me that's so greedy and stupid
and night and pride comes right before
the fall you have described most of the
cryptocurrency community and now the nft
community they're really quiet now yeah
they're not making much noise pipe down
where are all you people that said
George and I were frauds well they made
their Millions now they're on the
beaches Dave apparently they're not
tweeting anymore
that sounds like velocity banking to me
no they're probably back at work working
their normal job that's uh uh uh
Philosoraptor banking oh there you go
that's a whole new banking I'm signing
up for that one Chomp Chomp I know what
happened to the dinosaurs I'm not I'm
not touching that one with a 10 football
uh take 12 but this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey George Campbell here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsay show we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships George Campbell Ramsey
personality host of the smart money
happy hour co-host of it anyway is my
co-host and he is also the
very popular new launch on YouTube the
George Campbell YouTube show and uh
that's camel with a K you don't want to
miss that lots of snark there I'm a big
fan because I'm a big fan of snark
that's one of the reasons I'm a big
George fan phone number here is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five Jennifer is with us in
Austin Texas hi Jennifer how are you
good good how can we help
um I wanted to find out I have been
looking for a house for about nine years
and I found one but it's kind of a
flipper and it's about two million
dollars so I didn't know if it would be
wise in our situation
okay let's just back up looking for a
house for nine years is weird let's
start with that
okay we
are we impossible to manage a project
here so I kind of have to just remodel
something and hope that it's you know
we've got pretty good bones and the
property's good so
um why does it take nine years to
discover you need a general contractor
to build a house
no
well we um I I won't I do not want to
build a house here because I I'm in the
I'm in that industry but I don't want to
have to manage a project and their
contractors here are they're not
licensed so it's really hard to they
don't license general contractors in
Texas no Google it it's insane
like the Wild Wild West to construction
I don't even go into tall buildings here
if there are more than two floors I
won't go in them
that's engineering and that's also weird
Okay
um okay so you wanna
you you want to build you want to buy a
house for two million dollars that you
have to fix up and then you're gonna
flip it and you're gonna get the land no
no I'm just saying like it's not a
flipper then if you're not going to flip
it it's just you're buying a house it
needs a lot of work yeah it looks like
flipper conditions he likes why do you
want to buy this property then do you
have the money
it's beautiful well that's what I want
to talk to
talk before would be completely
different than this purchase we've
always saved enough cash where we just
did the tip so we wouldn't do a jumbo
loan we'd do whatever the maximum was
like our first house was like 417 I
think now it's up to like 500 something
for like before you go to a jumbo lawn
and then we put cash down and then do a
15-year mortgage and do 20 down and
that's the way we've always bought our
houses but this one just because I don't
think we have
enough I I think the payment would be
too high because interest rates are so
high right now that we wouldn't I think
we would have to do like a 20 or 30 year
mortgage
what you're saying is you just can't
afford the house
that's okay to say that out loud
Jennifer it's a two million dollar house
I know well we
yeah what is your income what's the
household income
together our base salaries is about 520.
okay and the thing is the reason we
don't have a lot of money saved is
because normally we don't work both at
the same time but just since I've been
working a lot more the last few years
I've enjoyed it so now I'm working all
the time
um I do Global architecture so
um
architecture and interior design not
really I do work for an engineering an
I.T company but it's construction
engineering so
I I do but I work for an I.T company
that's building their their facilities
all over the U.S so your household
income is 525 000 and why can't you put
a two million dollar house on a 15-year
because we've really been living beyond
our well not beyond our means it's
really what's in our means but like we
spent a lot of our savings like my
husband took two years off during covid
and we remodeled our house and we just
did about a I bought a house for my
daughter we just like spent a lot of
money and we normally have more savings
and we don't have
what was that I said I'm tired this is
y'all we've been running million miles
an hour with nothing to show for it oh
my gosh yeah so we well we've never
really had this much income steadily
we've had it for the last few years okay
if you've had it for two years or more
you can qualify for a 15-year mortgage
and you can afford a 15-year mortgage I
think we could no I know that we could
qualify for a 15-year mortgage
no no okay sorry I sorry I didn't mean
to say that I just don't want our house
payment to be that high because I know
my husband will be against that so
that's why I want to do like a 30 until
the 20 or a 30 until the interest rates
are lower no you take out a 15 and when
the interest rates are lower you
refinance
and if you're not willing to admit that
you're buying a two million dollar house
to your husband you shouldn't buy a two
million dollar house
um so I can't make this not be ex might
be two million dollars there's not a
technique for that it's two million
dollars
and um I I got a I got a feeling your
husband doesn't want to do a two million
dollar Fixer-Upper either so I think
there's probably more going on and
you've kind of gotten this romantic idea
that this land is beautiful and it makes
this whole project worthwhile
um
I I don't know if you guys together want
to sit down and look at the
trouble and the pain that doing a
remodel is going to be that you're going
to live in which is way different than
doing one that you're not going to live
in
that's a lot of pain it's a lot of
Heartache it's like building a house
except worse
um you know remodels are just horrid and
I've done a bunch of them and they're
just even when you're not going to live
in them they're a pain in the butt it's
easier to push it down start again
um and then um emotionally easier for
sure if you guys want to endure the pain
of that you have them Financial
wherewithal to do it and you're willing
to accept the reality of the payment
that a two million dollar loan takes on
both of you you and your husband then go
forward but I got a feeling that there's
in that in those guidelines I just gave
you that you're all are going to run
into all kinds of trouble and you just
you're wanting somebody to tell you you
can't afford it I think you can afford
it I just don't think you want to afford
it that's what I heard what'd you hear
well I'm hearing a lot of stress and I
don't know that this two million dollar
mortgage is going to alleviate any of
that and so they need to simplify their
life get their act together figure out
how to control the money that they're
bringing in but I would pause on this
decision it does not sound like they're
all over the place like yeah okay and
there's also I don't know million dollar
houses in Austin that are great so maybe
we could start there it doesn't have to
be the two million or bust yeah so I
think we have to back out and find out
what all of the options are before we
get Starry Eyed at one yeah
um
and I'll just go ahead and throw in here
too
um just just to be straight with you
Jennifer the idea that everyone in Texas
that lives in a home or has a
three-story building is incompetent and
all of them are about to fall in because
they don't license gc's is absurd
okay obviously there's quality buildings
in Texas that are not going to fall in
and obviously I did not know they didn't
license gc's but that doesn't change
anything for me because I've been in a
bunch of houses in Texas that are
wonderful properties and you're so brave
yeah I'm brave you went to the third
floor and everything I did I've been to
the 16th floor I mean it's scary you
know not not in a house but I mean golly
come on girl seriously this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
all right
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phone AAA
[Music]
825-5225
one of the things that we have to do
when we're managing our money is we're
managing our life
and we're making big decisions and lots
of decisions and when you find yourself
making
here's some things that will tell you if
you're making a wrong decision okay
because I making a wrong decision around
money particularly like a car purchase
or a house purchase or something of the
some other a big investment uh deciding
to go into crypto deciding to do
something stupid along you know getting
out of where you're getting ready to set
yourself back a decade by screwing up
by making a bad decision see we always
talk about wealth building and things to
do to build wealth I don't think we
spend enough time probably on how to
uh
stupid proof ourselves so we don't do
something stupid and offset all the good
work we did right so one of the things I
discovered about me and turns out it's
true of everyone is that right before I
right after I get desperate
I get stupid
and right after I get stupid I get broke
you know what I'm saying there's a close
connection when you feel desperation
trapped
I and you start your language will tell
you that you're that way I was forced to
we had no choice buy a car never in the
history of human races have been true
you were not forced they did not have a
gun
they don't do car reverse carjackings it
doesn't happen right so it doesn't
happen so you weren't forced you or in a
desperate situation on transportation
and so you Justified a dumb butt
decision to go to The Tote The Note lot
and pay double for the car at a 28
interest rate because you and then say
but I was forced you weren't forced you
were just stupid
I've been stupid too
right I just explained it right after I
felt desperate and trapped okay and so
when listen to your language and if your
language is indicating a sense of being
trapped a sense that there is no other
options
and in your language to yourself in this
decision making or to your spouse or
you're trying to talk into this is
bizarre then that tells you that you're
getting ready to screw up okay I'll give
you another example we run into George
every
property for rent
in x-town
is four thousand dollars a month make up
a number fill it in
you can't find them they don't exist
see these absolute hyperbole statements
are indications that you feel desperate
and stuck and so once you've decided
inaccurately that every property for
rent is four thousand dollars minimum in
this town
then you can justify buying something
you shouldn't be buying at a point in
your finances that you aren't ready to
buy you see what I'm saying yeah so when
you start making these fatalistic
absolute statements
that are that are overstated
then and when you say if it sounds
bizarre to you then that tells you
you're there and that was my that was my
question with my I I couldn't get it out
of my mouth fast enough in that last
call
because we've been looking for a
property in Texas for nine years
okay that's just weird no you haven't
or if you have you've got other issues
other than property looking takes you a
decade that it takes a decade in Texas
to find something to live in
that's just not true that's just that's
that smacks of weirdness and
uh desperation and you're getting ready
to make a mistake but what that leads to
then is I'm going to do a deal here that
I know I shouldn't be doing because for
nine years this is the only property see
the see that you know how that comes out
and I do that in my own head that's how
I recognize the drama queen it lives in
all of our heads and it's like you know
I'm so stuck rental prices are so high I
am forced to buy a house I can't afford
while I have six hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt well that's
just dumber and crap you know no it's
just not true okay not true and and so
oh the other one I love is
um
our house has mold
our children will die if we stay here
and
the only property we can find to live in
is sixty percent of our take-home pay
these are our two options
death of our children or bankruptcy
these are our two options because we
forced ourselves in desperation into
this false Narrative of fatalism
that I'm stuck and the only way out is
to go from one stupid horrible thing to
another stupid horrible thing and I'm
trying to justify it by saying it's the
only option you see what I'm doing oh
yeah and every time I do that in my head
I have lost
so much money
I just every time that fear-based
desperation leads you into that and and
I get the these are the actual calls I
get here you've heard them I'm getting
triggered Dave my PTSD is coming back
from the caller saying well there's no
used cars under 25 000 so we had to
finance one for 35 because what else are
you gonna do yeah you're just stuck I
mean because it's not on a used car
anywhere they're all the used cars in
America that's right now 25 000. so when
you start making these over the top
crazy butt statements what that states
is not the actual fact what it indicates
is your mindset is in desperation and
stuck fatalism there's a whiny toddler
inside all of us we just want the new
car just admit it you want the shinier
newer car well yeah but admitting it
would be dealing with me and I don't
want to deal with me instead I would
rather create this false Narrative of
the marketplace is forcing me into doing
things it's the economy High interest
rates that's just I mean it's forced me
the only way I could go to school was to
go four hundred thousand dollars of
student loan debt
it's the only way it was the only
possible other than joining the military
but only possible other than to say only
other than other than other oh my God
but the only part so now here I sit and
Biden won't forgive them and so I'm
screwed you know and now Sunday you have
to start paying payments again not
someday Sunday this coming Sunday
so but yeah but but every time you say
something with a bizarre set of
overstatement
that is indicating you're getting ready
to make a mistake because I've done this
I've I'm not making fun of y'all if
you've done it I'm not even making fun
of our last caller I mean it was a
little bit hard to keep up but I mean I
but even even aside from that I she just
was stuck and I want this and so I and I
don't think I should be doing it it
feels wrong but I've got to justify it
with everything else out here all the
three-story buildings and above are not
safe uh they don't have licensed
contractors you know all these other
wild and crazy stories out here in there
to justify the move and again that's not
picking on her she's sweet lady she's
trying to figure it out I appreciate her
calling if you call I'll pick on you too
but I'm picking on me and the same thing
because I'll tell you man some of the
dumbest butt stuff I've ever done is
when I was in facing uh bankruptcy I got
stuck in that and I thought there's no
way out there's nothing I don't know
what to do and I lost so stinking much
money
uh I made Decades of income evaporate in
in single Strokes of the pen because I
was desperate stuck
and fixated
and the one that goes with that also the
sister to it is greed and when you get
when you get all fired up and you're
like oh I'm gonna but if okay if the
system is broken
yet and the millennial can't get ahead
then the millennial has to do something
that's completely different crazy
shortcut exactly I need a Tick-Tock life
hack which is nothing down real estate
velocity banking is what we all need
velocity we need we need high speed
stupidity
High stupidity on high speed stupidity
on caffeinated stupidity that's what it
takes in today's world Dave yeah but
it's so true most of the calls on the
show is someone saying hey I've got
option A and option b and they're both
terrible what do I do and we say have
you ever thought about option C or D no
there's a lot of that and it involves
you instead of a shortcut it involves
that's how you know let me help you no
is a possible answer no it looks like
the only car you can find that suits
your needs is 25 000 and you're broke uh
answers no and it's a complete sentence
no
it's an interesting sound
two letters the silence that follows it
is definitely no
this is the Ramsey Show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsay we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than thirty
four thousand customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions and you can
come visit anytime you'd like we'd love
to have you on the debt free stage Jeff
and Pam are joining us hi guys how are
you good Dave we're better than we
deserve I love it welcome where do y'all
live we're outside of Philadelphia
Pennsylvania ah cool good to have you
welcome to Nashville and how much debt
have you paid off we paid off two
hundred thousand dollars yay and how
long did this take 56 months wow and
your range of income during that time
started at 132 000 and went to 154 000.
cool what do y'all do for a living I'm a
nurse practitioner and Dave I'm a high
school personal finance teacher oh wow
thank you yes yes yes
helping the Next Generation avoid
stupidity way to go man I love it cool
so what kind of what kind of debt was
the 200 000. it was our mortgage
house now you get to tell your class I
love it yeah weird people very weird no
mortgage at all what's this house worth
about five hundred thousand dollars yay
and how much in your nest egg in your
retirement uh so retirement's probably
like 300 000. all right bumping up on
getting ready to be baby steps
millionaires too yeah way to go guys
congratulations how old are you two 37.
oh man paid four house and almost
millionaires already look at you I'm so
proud of you good work good work tell us
how this story start so this story
started about 13 years ago when we were
dating he got me your Total Money
Makeover book no um so he's been this
nerd all along he's been the nerd I'm
definitely a free spirit here
um so I read that dating a personal
finance professor in high school you
know what's coming shocking you get a
personal finance book okay
um so I started paying off student loans
I had actually bought a new car out of
college so I was one of those yeah
worked on paying all that off we got
married and all the money we got from
the wedding went to finish paying off my
debt wow so we became debt free once
already yay
um and then we ended up buying our home
we had our first daughter Caroline we
ended up going through FPU class in
2017. um yeah so then uh I I just got
this bug for helping people with
finances so we actually came down here
and met with you guys in 2018 for uh the
financial Coast Master training yeah
um and so it became a financial coach
and we've I've LED FPU at my church and
couple other churches in our area
um and
at that point I'm like I can't get
enough of this and so I was already
teaching something else and decided all
right we got to change what's going on
in our society and so I went back and
got some more education and uh became a
personal finance teacher and I think
five years later that's kind of where we
are now wow look at you why'd it go man
thank you thanks for all the help my
goodness that's powerful I mean you guys
really drink the Kool-Aid and it worked
out for you that's incredible yeah yeah
so 56 months paying off this mortgage
where people cheering you on did they
think it was weird did you keep it to
yourselves I think it varies um you know
if people ask us we'd be happy to talk
about it um we actually had a chart
um I made a chart with our house on it I
drew a picture of our house and I
colored in and I had it hanging in our
kitchen so people came over they saw it
hanging in the kitchen and we would
color off every six thousand dollars I
think our Mark was
um yeah what a great conversation
starter they're like did your kids draw
that you're like no I did yeah but we
did have some cheerleaders uh my one
buddy Frank Nevis he and I have led
personal finance are our Financial Peace
University multiple times together my
parents are huge supporters of us they
actually introduced us to Dave Ramsey
when I was 19. I remember looking at the
Ben and Arthur chart of compound
interest this is generational oh it is
and uh and that's kind of why we're
doing this too um you know we have two
kids under the age of seven and uh you
know talk about really emotional here
but talking about changing family trees
yeah um and that's kind of what our
motivation was at least my motivation
was for all of this and our kids hear it
all the time our daughter's now in
second grade but when she was in
kindergarten they had if you were given
a hundred dollars what would you do with
it and she said I would save it she
wrote that on her paper and everyone
else was buying things
I actually did I would save it I love it
so they're used to it they hear us
talking about budgeting we had a big
goal after we paid off the house was to
go to Disney World so that's upcoming
this fall yay so they knew that when
Mommy and Daddy paid the house off then
we get to go to Disney World yeah and we
always joke that you know if they had a
friend that went to Disney World they're
like oh their parents must have paid off
their house to go to to go to Disney
World so that's amazing no that's kind
of just how we do it yeah
we're weird
Disney should have such a program but
they don't yes
probably limit the old uh lines on the
rides
absolutely good for you guys well done
you guys very well done all right so the
kiddos have been involved you have
changed your family tree Your Heroes
proud of you thanks well done all right
let's bring them up and introduce them
what are their names and ages all right
so we have Samuel Samuel is five and we
have Caroline she's coming up now and
she is seven all right all right and all
grown up I love it very well done good
job you guys what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is and almost
being a millionaire by the time you're
37. the budget absolutely the budget and
not keeping up with the Joneses the
contentment I follow Rachel Cruz I've
done all of that
um that's huge especially in our age
with our friends and seeing what they're
doing yeah just being happy with what
you have
um you know our we don't have the nicest
house we don't we have 10 year old cars
and they work just fine and
um you know we're just very content
people yeah way to go you gosh way to go
very proud of you very proud of you
godliness with contentment is a great
gain very good well done well we got the
uh baby or we got the
the uh live and give box for you which
includes the baby steps Millionaire's
book which you almost are but you'll be
soon excellent and Total Money Makeover
book you'll find somebody to give that
to in a Financial Peace University
membership and as lifetime coordinators
you've been doing it forever you'll find
somebody to help with that I'm sure as
you coordinate more classes thanks for
leading the classes and for being a
coach and for being a teacher leading
the stuff my goodness yeah incredible
everything you've taught it this stuff
more than I have I believe well done
very well done you guys I'm very proud
of you all right Jeff and Pam Caroline
and Samuel yeah your house is paid off
and everything and now we're going to
Disney officially weird people making
you did paid off 200 000 in 56 months
making 132 to 154. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
done it
they'll remember it now well it's going
to be on YouTube forever so when they're
grown adults they'll be scrolling back
to the debt free scream their parents
did yeah like I remember when I was six
I went over to that Ramsay place man my
parents paid off the house that'll be
pretty cool I feel like it'd be hard for
them to now live a life of debt after
this experience seeing what their
parents did changing the family tree you
gotta hope they don't run the other way
yeah it can happen but um you know you
can you can have a prodigal show up but
but the way you change your family tree
what's interesting is the thing I love
about that idea is that uh Proverbs 22 7
says the rich rules over the poor the
borrower is slave to the lender the
verse before that
is 22 6 and it says train up a child in
the way he should go wow and when he's
old he will not depart from it and if
you so if you take the numbers out it
just says train up a child in the way he
should go and when he's old he'll not
depart from it the rituals over the poor
and the borrower slave to the lender
train your child that wow
and teach one's a parenting thing and
one's a money thing but it sounds like
you're teaching your kids stay out of
debt that's a continued thought what do
I know but we'll see we'll have to talk
about that in heaven make sure I got
that right but uh the theologians out
there everywhere questioning my use of
Proverbs but there we go and it's always
always happened since I started there we
go you guys are very cool that was a
very neat uh the emotion in his voice
he's teaching kids in high school he
taught the class in his church totally
Financial Peace University coordinator
became a Ramsey coach the whole like you
said drink the Kool-Aid but that that's
all because this stuff matters to him
yeah well and his parents at 19 was like
hey you got to check out this Ramsay
stuff and so introducing that early on
got him on this path and now he's going
to train up his kids this way and the
kids are going to trade up their kids
that way you know what so what we're
saying is if you can get your 19 year
old to not be stupid it helps your
grandkids in the future if nothing else
do it for the grandkids do it for the
grandkids that aren't here yet
yeah teach your kids so that your
grandkids can have some sense
there's an idea well how many people
call in and say Dave I wish I knew this
stuff when I was in my 20s and 30s man I
did some dumb stuff yeah you can if
you're a parent out there you have a
chance at Redemption here yeah for sure
and we've got the you know if you want
to teach little kids we've got all that
Financial Peace Jr yeah they got the new
uh the brand new kids it is incredible
it's incredible I want to get one for my
little girl Dave she's a month old but
you better believe yeah she's already
saving her money I know you you'll be
sending her to the salt mines
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
over your head with student loans and
tired of getting calls from collection
agencies if private student loan debt is
taking away your financial piece and you
don't see any way out you need why refi
they're not a debt settlement company
and they're not connected to a bank why
refi refinances defaulted private
student loans that other places won't
touch and gives you a custom loan built
for you based on your ability to pay so
when you refinance your private student
loan debt with why refi you'll have a
payment you can afford with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lump sum payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Kathy is with us in
Columbus Ohio hi Kathy welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi there hey what's up
um well my question is I'm about 43 000
in debt right now some student loans
with little income and I'm just
wondering what my next steps are okay uh
42 000 student loan debt what is your
income
but I estimate about 2 800 a month
okay
so you're making a little over thirty
thousand a year how old are you
I'm 22. and what's your degree in
um well I'm only
okay and are you still going to school
um at the moment no because 15 000 of
that 43 000 that I'm in debt is with the
school itself
um and my credit score is not great and
I can't find a loan to cover in my last
semester which is that 15 000 so they
won't even enroll me back into school
until that 15 000 is paid off okay you
only like one semester graduating
we have about 3
about three months okay all right so
signing up for more of this fun doesn't
sound fun does it
not really so okay is this all the debt
you have
um yeah currently just the student loans
okay
well let me ask you it sounds like
you're saying you need a new career plan
well
that's just what I've always wanted to
do is teach music
so it just if there's a way around it I
would love
to jump onto it but if that's what I got
to do I got to do what I got to do
okay well there's um so you're a
musician I assume
correct okay and what is your specialty
okay so voice
right okay good all right
um
okay unless you were teaching in a
High School setting
a degree I mean there's no degree
required to give voice lessons as an
independent person you know that right
correct correct okay
um so the only the only way you would
have to have a degree requirement is if
you were going into a classroom setting
of some kind but anything that was
Private or one-off
um
you you certainly could start doing at
this moment because you obviously you
obviously have a great voice and you
have a passion for teaching people to
sing that's wonderful
that's wonderful okay so
um
all right so I I'll just uh
put my muddy boots on and walk all in
your dream for a minute I already am so
let me walk around some more okay
all right so your dream of spending
a hundred thousand dollars or more
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
total when you're all said and done
probably to get a degree to teach music
in high school and make forty or fifty
thousand dollars a year uh doesn't have
a good return on investment
it's a bad choice mathematically so
since our Dream process is becoming a
nightmare I'm going to suggest we live
the dream in such a way that it becomes
not a nightmare and that's what I was
starting to do there I was starting to
mess with it you know your your your way
of implementing your passions and your
skills okay
and this is what Ken Coleman that works
here as a Ramsay personality does every
day on his show he helps people align
with their passions and their skills and
point them in the direction a practical
application of that that is not
necessarily involves a four-year degree
in your case you can't afford a
four-year degree right now and you're
trapped as a bartender with a great
voice right now
so we need a different plan it's what I
think just looking at it as your ugly
uncle that loves you okay and so your
old ugly uncle that loves you and tells
you the truth says uh we need a
different plan than classroom teaching
uh because it's not worth the money you
will spend for the money versus the
money you will make in order to
um
be able to teach voice in a classroom
setting now later on when you're making
some serious money but I I'll give you a
crazy example okay I had a friend
um I'm in Nashville everybody in
Nashville is a musician okay but this
lady was a fabulous concert level
pianist okay fabulous and you're in
Nashville and so I mean you you're your
studio or you're on the road or you're
unemployed those are your three options
when you're doing that okay in this town
right yeah and she won't be on the road
Studio stuff was hard to break into but
she was fabulous she ended up building a
large I'm talking like 18 teachers
working for her piano lessons
the company I don't know what you call
that I don't know but yeah but people
she rented a building in a warehouse
district and filled it up with pianos
the piano place would put them in there
on a deal so the kids would get hooked
on their brand right and they come in
there and Mom and Dad drop them off for
piano lessons and she was a huge but the
absolutely zero degree required I don't
even know if the lady had a degree but
she I've seen her play and I knew her I
mean she's a good personal friend and
she but she built this Mega well Meg I
mean a nice sized business she was
making a whole lot more than the teacher
at the co at the high school I can
promise you that okay uh teaching all
these children and and adults piano
lessons
um I don't know why you couldn't do
something like that
as your dream
and not be 150 000 in debt for the
opportunity
and it starts with it starts with you
starting you know finding a couple
people that need voice lessons in your
town and just cue them up and help them
in the meantime probably thinking about
what I can do is a side job or a
different better job to go make some
dadgum money get the student loan paid
off uh because I don't want you 32 years
old trapped in a bar still waiting on
this dream
right that's what I'm worried
in the meantime could you get a better
job bartending at a higher end
restaurant for example and double your
income doing that
well I actually just did that so the the
income that I gave you is my estimated
new income as of this week that I just
started a new more higher end kind of
job that still feels low for a higher
end bartender making 30 grand I mean
some of these are making six figures or
more yeah so that I would at least look
into hey what do I need to work overtime
right now do I need to do those vocal
lessons on the side but right now we got
an income problem let's clean up the
debt and let's chase that dream later on
down the road yeah I I
the way the so the answer to your
question that you called about is how do
I pay off my student loans
um you have to anytime you have a debt
you have to look at your the two pieces
you gave us the income that you have
versus the debt that you have and we
call that the shovel to whole ratio
around here how big a shovel your income
do you have to get out of the hole the
debt and so if you call me up and you
have a four hundred thousand dollar
income big shovel but you got 300 000
worth of debt well you've got big debt
big shovel you're good that's about not
a it's not a one fun place but it's a
ratio you can deal with your problem is
you're upside down you got a small
shovel and medium-sized debt
and so the reason this whole discussion
unfolded was we were trying to think
with you how we can help you get your
shovel bigger your income bigger to
knock the debt out right quick and then
let's move with our whole career
movement and how we can pull this off
and either start and run a business or
you know again I I don't know what the
voice scene the vocal scene is in
Columbus Ohio I don't know anything
about it but um uh I'm gonna start
working in that area and trying to
figure out ways to use my talent and get
paid because
if you can sing to the level that you
can teach others then you can sing to
the level you can make money with your
voice
and uh yeah and I I had a similar amount
of debt I had 36 000 in student loans
and at the time I had an entry level
salary and I was like well I'm I can't
just go double my income at my at the
company so I can go out and I started
making websites I did musics gigs I was
licensing my songs Through websites I
was doing Uber Lyft I was doing it all
and all of that combined gave me the
margin to tackle this debt in 18 months
and so it may seem like insignificant at
the time but all that little stuff adds
up if you're willing to just work your
tail end off exactly literally yeah I
mean that's just not going to happen
doing 35 hours a week no you're gonna
have to go crazy for a short period of
time and you know I I don't think I'd
sign back up for the deal you were
signed up for I want to change your
direction hang on I'm going to send you
a copy of Ken Coleman's book paycheck to
purpose and also I'm going to send you
the assessment that he has on helping
you pick out your career track so I want
to leave your dream with you not your
nightmare this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions it's the Ramsay
show where we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships George Campbell
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
he is also the co-host of smart money
happy hour and the host of the very
popular new Ramsay networks production
called The George Campbell show on
YouTube Campbell with a K be sure and
check it out lots of good stuff going on
there open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Bethany is in
Philadelphia Hi Bethany welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey thanks for taking my call I really
appreciate your time and your wisdom
sure what's up
um well first I wanted to say
um thank you for the
opportunity to talk with you both
George I think Mia Jane is the most
beautiful girl in the whole wide world
oh thank you
and Dave
um I have on my bucket list to have
dinner with you and Sharon someday so
I'm not sure if that's true for on this
side of heaven but in heaven
we will probably have a great time yeah
we'll pull up to A Feast for sure how
can we help today absolutely so
my biggest question
is I'm wondering
family business
if it's something that I can keep that's
metaphorical right I just want to make
sure exactly okay exactly or
um you never know
am I doing a good job so for the most
part my parents
retired early and decided to start a
coffee roasting business
in 2005.
my dad suddenly passed away in
2019 and
I was given the opportunity to keep it
going okay so I've left my full-time job
and thankfully my dad taught me
everything about roasting coffee already
um
and I think that
this was what God prepared me to do but
I'm
desperate to know
am I really doing a good job or are you
making money
how much money are you making
so in 2020
IO my net profit was seven thousand
in 2021 my net profit was seven thousand
but in 2022 my net profit was 25.
and then so far this year my net profit
is 52.
what you do different that caused the
spike
I'm busting my rear end so I'm working
24 7. I am I know you say it's a it's a
treadmill well you're selling you're
selling coffee more how are you selling
more coffee
[Music]
wholesale
that you weren't that you weren't in
when you made seven
right so you've created this you've
created distribution and you're doing
some kind of marketing because they're
buying it
yes and that is my actually my degree is
in marketing good because you need to
sell some coffee
I do
how big is the team is it just you do
you have people working for you as a
family
so I took over right before covid
and then had to let five people go
during covet so it's just myself
and my husband who retired from
construction because
we're dealing with cancer number two hmm
who's we um
John my husband your husband has got
cancer
yeah oh my gosh for the second time
yeah for the second time oh my gosh
sorry so we're thank you all right so uh
yeah you are I mean this is an entree
leadership call for those of you don't
know I do a podcast called entree
leadership and I had a number one
best-selling book on by the same title
on how to run a business and there are
five stages in business what she was
referring to is the first stage is the
treadmill operator where you're by
yourself all of the revenue and
Productions dependent on you to level up
and move to the next stage of business
you've got to get it to where all the
revenue and the production is not
dependent on you and that is your next
move you got to level up on that so
um if you are you know you have Reason
for Hope
okay your whole I mean because the
numbers are giving you Reason for Hope
agreed
I I totally agree but I want to make
sure that I'm not just
this is not a facade in my brain well if
if the 52 000 is not there then it's a
facade but if there's a 52 000 versus 28
versus seven that's called a trend
okay
and so I mean that's kind of exciting I
mean if you can keep that hockey stick
up into the right movement going you're
at 500k in in 20 minutes the way we're
going I mean this is you got you know
and you do need to get to 500 I mean
this is not it's not it's not fun at the
level you're at all you do is work right
now no you smell like coffee all the
time you smell coffee all the time
everything's about coffee you're sick of
coffee right now
right yeah so you I mean you I've been
there not with coffee but with you know
the smell of paper books right same crap
right so uh anyway right yeah so you you
got to get the the next thing we need to
start talking about who we can add to
get the production off of you
and how that increases profit because
you're out there selling more and then
who we can add that's out there moving
the product into some of these
distribution Outlets called a sales
person and that'll the positional
Revenue justify itself very quickly but
where you need to where you would
say I'm not resuscitating I'm not I'm
not uh I'm I'm not in a facade I'm not
in self-denial is where we're making
very solid wise steps to gently grow
this business and get it all off of your
back
okay you need to do that for the sake of
the business you need to do that because
you're fighting cancer inside your house
and that takes a lot of energy
yeah it does and um okay and it's okay
by the way
if you say we're going to fight cancer
we're closing Coffee Bean down I'm gonna
go get a job that I don't have to think
about all this crap and I can just love
my husband while we're fighting cancer
that'd be an okay move but that really
wouldn't be because the business failed
it would be because you don't have the
extra energy to do both things right now
right and that is a little tough yeah
I'll give you permission to do either
one
okay give yourself permission to do
either one you're not a bad person
either way and your dad didn't leave
this to you to trap you he left this to
you to be a blessing at the point it
ceases being a blessing it's no longer
from your dad
thank you for saying that yeah I told
our kids around here every time we have
our Dave dies this year meeting where we
go over everything you all are going to
do around here if I die this year I tell
them every time we were together I tell
the leaders do not keep a business unit
a business concept alive under the name
of Dave always wanted to do no bullcrap
Dave's gone
you know so that you you got to release
from that but you're a good lady you got
a lot on your plate and I think you got
a business that'll work here if you if
you have the bandwidth to do that and
fight cancer and I don't know if I would
but um you know it's that's you and
John's choice
so hang on we'll send you a copy of the
book entree leadership and God bless you
darling you're a tough you're a warrior
this is a Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
personalities my co-host David is in
Chattanooga hi David welcome to the show
hey Dave hey George good to talk to you
today you too how can we help sir
well I'm hoping you can help me here
with something I'm a renter I have zero
debt my retirement account is a tsp with
about 40 000. my company kicks in or
matches about 4.5
I contribute 16
I make about 125 a year I have 200 000
sitting in the bank doing nothing
and I'd like to get a house with some
property and I'm just checking in with
you to see what would you do if you were
me
it sounds like you're uh ready to be a
homeowner you've done really well man
what's stopping you from using a large
chunk of that 200 as a down payment
um just a I'm a terrible procrastinator
I think
so we're 49 we're renting still you're
in Chattanooga have you started to look
at properties in that area to see
something reasonable in your price range
in your budget
um nothing just other than glancing at
the internet but I have not seriously
begun looking
okay
uh generally when I procrastinate on
something it means I'm with me I don't
know about you but with me it means um
I'm either distracted with other things
that are better or I'm afraid of facing
that thing
yes probably the latter okay what is it
you're afraid of do you know
um
just uh spending a chunk of money and
going into debt making a mistake
right afraid of making a mistake
this is a huge I mean it took forever to
get the 200k
devastate you that would that that's how
I would be if I were in your shoes does
that sound right
yeah it actually didn't take too long I
just been working non-stop how long did
it take the last four
uh about five years okay so let's say if
you saved up 205 years let's say you had
a 200 000 mortgage could you pay it off
in five years
yes there we go okay so you got a 400
000 budget then
you make 125 you have a great income and
so what's stopping you from putting a
huge down payment as big as you can go
keep an emergency fund aside in that
savings account but outside of that
let's put that money down on the house
let's get aggressive at the mortgage and
pay this thing off in our early 50s and
retire with dignity and money in the
bank you said something about a piece of
land
you want a little space
yeah I want some Elbow Room yeah what
are you what are you renting now
I pay 700
okay it's uh well the other thing is
causing you to procrastinate is you're a
cheapskate and you don't want to spend
money
is that a fair assessment
you're my kind of people man
it doesn't sound like you have any
lavish highlights
yeah I like to get value for my money
yeah let's say yeah that's where that's
Frugal that's what we'll say instead of
Cheapskate cheapscape coming from me is
love language don't take it wrong all
right so uh yeah you just don't want to
spend the money you got 750 rent my God
and you got a place you already like if
you could buy that place for 750 bucks a
month you'd already bought it right
um well like I said I'm not
uh I'd like to get out where there's a
some wide open space Oh a little more
even than you got now okay
yes I there's I'm in a little town here
so yeah it's just city streets and
sidewalks but oh you're not you don't
have Elbow Room where you are then okay
all right so dude just jump on the
dadgum internet and pull up like uh real
tracks or something and start looking at
property that's for sale I do it all the
time and I'm not even looking for
anything I'm just like looking at real
estate and I think you need someone in
your corner to help move this along
because you've been procrastinating and
so I would also jump on
ramseysolutions.com get in touch with
one of our Ramsay trusted Real Estate
Pros yeah that's a good idea they'll
start going hey David here's seven
properties based on everything you told
me that are in your price range yeah I
think we need someone else to help us
get a little more excited and on fire
about this movie I mean if they found
you're not going to find something if
you're not looking
gotcha you know so start start poking
around it doesn't cost anything to look
and then when you find something you
don't need you're not in a rush you
don't have to be you don't have to buy
something stupid just to buy something
there's no uh false urgency here but
dude you do not need to be 59 and still
not own a house
and have 500 000 in the bank so your
current trajectory needs to change
agreed
I agree now let me get let me get you
your input on this tsp this Thrift
Savings Plan your federal employee
yes yeah what do you do
I work for a utility
TVA
yeah okay cool all right and um yeah so
tsp is fine I mean we work for federal
employees for years we always put 80
into the C 20 s and 20 and 10 10 into s
and ten percent into I that's what I
always do when I'm doing with TSP the C
plan is done really well the others
aren't they they're not great but
they're doing good and uh that gives you
good diversification and you've got the
match and just crank that puppy up but I
would crank it back down to only 15 that
you're you're putting in 16 you said I
bring it back down to 15. and I throw
the rest of it at this house you get the
house paid off but the land and house
the Elbow Room place that but dude where
you live is some of the most beautiful
country
in the world
I mean you can get a piece of ground out
there with some tree some Tennessee
trees on it oh man
dude I mean you you ought to be able if
you because you're willing to live
outside of Chattanooga a ways a lot of
TVA stuff going on
a small town outside of Chattanooga I
got an idea what we're dealing with and
so yeah that's that's fine yeah you're
in good shape and um but yeah find you
um what you're saying is is the land and
you tell the smart or tell the uh real
estate agent that Ramsey trusted real
estate agent when you call them that the
land is the most important part for you
the housing is the second most important
part because some people want a house
with some land you want to land with a
house
and um
yeah I
yes you need to get you're right George
and the thing about them shoveling stuff
at you is they're not going to pressure
you into buying something you don't want
or need but they are a great source of
information and agents run into stuff
that's not yet listed yes they'll call
you up and go hey Farmer John over there
he's got a place and well now is a
really good time if you've got some
money to begin into real estate
absolutely a great time to buy you could
even maybe get one of those things
called a deal hasn't been seen in a
while
I hadn't heard of those everyone spooked
by the interest rates but that's that's
right David's out here too don't use the
word deal around real estate that's a
weird that's a weird word but yeah
that's what David needs that to feel
like that he can justify this purchase
yeah like he got a deal he's like I've
been in Frugal yeah five percent off
gotta get value for my money there you
go dude go buy something give yourself a
timeline I'm gonna look aggressively
until I find the right thing within 18
months
or some number I don't care but don't
just kick the can down the road do
nothing and look up with a bigger pile
of money and no real estate you want to
be in the real estate game as a
long-term part of your life and your
portfolio because it goes up in value
because it's the largest line item that
750 rents not gonna be 750 rent forever
about the only thing you can count on
with rent is it goes up every year
so a hundred percent of the time 10
years from now rents higher
and real estate values are higher a
hundred percent
that's a pretty good chance and your
payment's not higher because you took a
fixed rate 15-year where the payment's
no more than a fourth year take-home pay
and you don't have it paid off before 10
years gets here the way we're talking
about so you got a good plan here but
you need to execute you need to get up
off your tail end and go get something
similar to those who have those low
mortgage interest rates he's got this
low rent that he's just it's so hard to
let go he doesn't want to have a higher
payment but he's also going to be a
homeowner with an appreciating asset at
all for a short period of time give us
something that gives you a reason to
work a little more you can tell you're
going to want that debt out of his life
fast oh good I love it love it love it
love it this is the Ramsey Show
thank you
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today a couple
things happening here around Ramsey one
we launched a podcast today called real
estate the Ramsey Way brand new podcast
on Apple Spotify YouTube the Ramsey
Network app wherever it is you get your
podcast and what it is it's the best of
real estate calls from this show in a
whole series that we developed into a
podcast so if you want specific real
estate stuff uh curated for you and jump
it on there check it out real estate the
Ramsay way second thing is one week from
tomorrow for most of you October the 3rd
is the launch date for the brand new Dr
John deloney book those of you that
ordered one already it will be shipped
to where it lands at your place sometime
right around then it's called building a
non-anxious life we live in a very
anxious world anxiety-ridden world and
there's a way to build a life to deal
with a lot of that and Dr John has laid
that out with the six daily choices to
help you do that it is a powerful book
very proud of this book it will be we've
already sold a bazillion of them it will
come out as a number one bestseller I'm
sure based on the numbers anyway it's
just crazy so unless somebody just has
an unbelievable Blockbuster the same
week and beats us out but this thing's
Gone Bananas it's very popular so 20
book but if you pre-order it before
launch date and before October the 3rd
you'll get 75 dollars in free bonus
items including the audiobook and the
ebook so we're going to bribe you to buy
it early that's what it amounts to so uh
because it helps with the marketing it
helps us get all the numbers up and
that's perfect for us we love we love
being generous so building a non-anxious
life Dr John deloney you can get that at
ramseysolutions.com in the store on the
debt free stage right outside my window
right here in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions Brad is with us hey Brad how
are you doing good today welcome good to
have you where do you live uh Eastern
Iowa just north of uh Davenport Iowa
okay 20 miles yeah fun welcome to
Nashville how much data have you paid
off 104 000. I love it how long did that
take two years eight months eight days
almost to the hour I love it
uh very cool and what was your range of
income during that two years eight
months and eight days 105 110. cool what
do you do for a living
so I've been into trades All My Life
um I was a journeyman sheet metal worker
stainless steel welder and now I've
taken some of those support skills and I
work for a commercial roofer oh wow very
good okay yeah man doing well
congratulations thank you good work so
what kind of debt was the 104 000 it was
uh it was my home
look at you paid for a house a weird guy
welcome man good to have you good stuff
what's this house worth so it's not a
big number it's only 155 000. but yours
it's all mine yeah nobody else getting
that no it's got zero payments that's
the only number we care about yep it's
awesome yeah we've done detailed
research 100 of the foreclosures occur
on the home of the mortgage so yeah
there you go man good stuff well done
man how's it feel to be free
so it feels awesome
um but one thing that um when I went to
make my final payment
um I was a little disappointed because
there was no fan for a party at the bank
no confetti and uh and you expected some
I thought maybe they'd be a little
excited too yeah yeah they're kind of
disappointed actually they they like
seeing you around there
oh my gosh that's so fun good for you
yeah a buddy of mine is a country music
guy around here wrote a hit song and
when it hit they uh he had a farm at uh
Farm Bureau at the Farm Bank what do you
call Farm Credit Farmer's Credit and he
went over and paid it off and they said
we'll see you and he said no you won't
you never see me again I'm calm good for
you man congratulations I love it well
done so what started you on this journey
two years and eight months ago so it
started way before that I've known about
you for many many years
um and I was married and I got divorced
four years ago actually today four years
ago today after 37 years oh I'm sorry
and uh I thought you know
this is my opportunity to see if this
stuff really works like I believe it
will
it works yeah it works so I had nobody
to answer to about myself nobody nobody
had to convince anymore yeah nope yeah
I'm sorry for that but I'm happy you did
it congratulations thank you well done
wow so two years after that you decided
I'm gonna pay off this house did you
just have the mortgage at that point no
other debt and you went I don't need
this thing hanging around anymore like a
pet yeah so when I got divorced I didn't
have any debt and uh walked away with a
little bit of cash
and took your guys's advice just wait a
year at least till you do anything
I only waited about eight months but
it was hard to pull the trigger to let
the cash go for the down payment
and then I knew I did the 15 year I knew
I wanted to pay it off early
um so that first
not the first week after but the week
after that I started making an extra 25
bucks a week extra payment
I went back into my budget that first
month well I can squeeze out hundreds of
dollars every week
and I had it down to where it's gonna be
about five and a half years
and I did FPU
um beginning of last year and I talked
to my coordinator Theresa Hart outside
of class
and because I was funding my 401k and
Ira full 100 percent and
um not doing it the Ramsey way
and I asked her is that the right thing
to do at my age and she asked me one
question she said why would you want
that debt I said well I'm going to run
some numbers in and uh and I got it down
to where I could have it paid off in
about three and a half years and I just
kept squeezing the budget and got it
down to two years and eight months and
um wow you just you were living on
nothing I mean you were throwing a 50k a
year at this thing yeah it um I mean I
was putting 65 to 80 percent of my
monthly take-home pay to this mortgage
wow to get it done I mean there's
there's some weeks I take 50 bucks for
groceries and the one the rest of them
went to the uh
to the mortgage now that you're free was
it worth it oh yeah in Spades do it
again huh yeah well I'm not going to do
it again I said you would do it if you
had to yeah no thank you no thank you
I'm good with this house yeah I paid for
a house by the way yeah I love it well
congratulations man thank you very much
so there's there's two other people I'd
like to thank also while I'm up here and
one is Tammy she um she's a good friend
and
when I would start to put these numbers
together and start squeezing things down
um she was the one I would bounce things
off of to make sure I wasn't forgetting
some make sure I was on the right track
and she she was a good friend and then
there's Becky
um she was just she was actually my real
estate agent when I bought the house and
became a good friend and um she checked
in every once in a while just to make
sure I was eating right make sure you're
eating yeah she did that too yeah he
quit eating but he got out of debt
way to go win well it sounds like you
got some good people on your car in your
in your corner encouraging you you gotta
have that you gotta have cheerleaders
and people you trust that uh that you
trust love you enough to tell you the
truth and uh that's handy so a good FPU
coordinator good stuff very good stuff
man so what's the next big thing
um I'm gonna start doing some work on
the house there you go hey um
I I put a lot of stuff on hold you know
and something broke or whatever can I
patch This Together can I do it myself
or whatever and I need to go back
through and just start updating some
things so okay yeah you'll have a whole
new place in a year or two then I hope
so no payments in the world making a
hundred and something thousand yeah yeah
pretty cool place to be yep how old are
you 59 yeah so you're ready to go way to
go man thank you so proud of you that's
good stuff very well done hey we've got
the live and give bundle for you this is
baby steps millionaires book which is
your next stop and of course The Total
Money Makeover book and a Financial
Peace University membership and I'm sure
you got good use for all of that with
all these people in your life so
congratulations I'm proud of you good
bounce good bounce back for you thank
you gave you a good goal and you turned
it around beautifully very very well
done all right it's Brad and Davenport
Iowa area 104 000 paid off in two years
and eight months house and everything
making 105 to 110. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
I'm dead free yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
I love it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
our scripture today Proverbs 15 22 plans
fail for lack of counsel but with many
advisers they succeed
the version I like is in the multitude
of council there is safety Theodore
Roosevelt said the only man who never
makes mistakes is the man who never does
anything
that's true I like the other one of
Henry I'm just keep adding to these
today but Henry Ford said um uh those
who never make mistakes work for those
of us that do oh I like that that's a
good one that one's very good very cool
stuff so George you have a blow up on uh
freaking car payment video on YouTube
it's like gone viral it hit a nerve yeah
I mean like a half a million views
almost immediately you know what are you
doing you're just saying the same thing
you've been saying Dave I said it more
interestingly that's true you did do
that but yeah so what did you say about
car payments well we walk through the
numbers you know I like to look at the
research and the facts and I talk about
the fact that auto loans have now
surpassed student loan debt as far as
Consumer Debt goes which blew my mind
1.7 trillion yep and there's a hundred
and eight million auto loans out there
in the US alone okay and there's not
that many more adults in the U.S which
tells you most people it was the
shocking thing that made it go viral
well we've walked through the idea that
if you invest that car payment it could
turn into millions of dollars we talk
about the idea yeah that you're paying
for this appreciating asset every month
and by the time you're done paying for
it that 40 000 car you paid 50 000 for
and it's worth 16. I am best and not
only I and here's the craziest part Dave
it had the least amount of hatred of any
of the videos we've ever done 3 300
comments wow and people from the car
business they started jumping in here
too positively yeah
this is crazy one guy said I've been in
the car business for 49 years he said we
joke out loud it's not a car it's a debt
system cars have financed my life all
these years your advice is 100 right on
I'm a finance manager at a car
dealership you're spot on I see people
making payments that are 40 or 50
percent of their paycheck just for
status I drive a Nissan kicks that I
paid 20K for even though I can afford
much more this is the finance manager at
the Nissan wow
yeah well this is wild and all these
folks and I worked in the automotive
industry for decades did detailed
consumer demographic research the
disturbing truth is the Auto industry is
addicted to the consumers you're
describing people lease or buy more than
they can afford they replace the vehicle
sooner than they need to and this
industry enables this by Finance
refinancing negative equity on traded
Vehicles we get those calls all the time
okay how are you that underwater well I
rolled over the negative equity and
they're offering all the zero percent
financing which is paid for by the way
by them increasing the transaction price
it's not a generous gift from the
dealership and so they're they're saying
what do they find where do they find
your YouTube video oh YouTube okay you
can just search George camel on YouTube
the video is called why is no one
talking about America's wealth kill is
it on the George Campbell show it's on
the George Campbell show that's right oh
okay so this was a video that the team
put together it's 10 minutes long and of
course it's filled with snark and memes
and research and humor and all that fun
stuff but I just wanted to make one
video to go hey if someone calls in they
go why shouldn't I finance my car I can
just send them this link and go here's
why there you go watch this 10 minute
video Kevin is in Irvine California oh
That's not Kevin I pushed the wrong
button that's Kevin hi Kevin how are you
George I am one month ahead of you on
the fatherhood train oh congratulations
I'm a parenting expert now so let me
know if you need any advice
cool one month into this twice as much
experience as you do that's right
oh that's perfect thanks for calling in
man how can we help
so related to being a father I was just
talking to our smart investor Pro about
opening a 529 plan and I said how what's
the yearly limit of what I can put in he
said there isn't a yearly limit I'm like
oh well I don't want to put in too much
because what if our kid doesn't end up
going to college and he said well with
the new rules you can enroll whatever
isn't used for college right into your
Roth IRA and then I said hang on then
why would I ever invest in anything
except for the 529 if it's essentially a
Roth IRA with no limits that I can get
to early for educational purposes it
does have a lot it does have limits on
what you can roll to the raw it's thirty
five thousand and you can't do it you
can't do it till the kid is 30. I was
missing yeah so there's some stipulation
I was missing yeah okay there's all
kinds of restrictions on the rollover
that make it not that good a deal yeah
and you can do it you can do it but
there's restrictions on it and
um the uh
yeah yeah no I would not over fund your
529 at today's world I would under fund
your 529.
gotcha okay because they probably you
probably are going to have other wealth
especially if you're following us that
you can pay cash for whatever they want
to do for education and
um you know we're talking about a
two-month-old right
yeah okay the higher ed landscape is
going to change so much in the next 18
years as the student loan epic failure
debacle unfolds and Pops this bubble
they have been over charging for too
long and it's come home to roost and
people are not going to college in
record numbers
um and that's going to drive the demand
the lack of demand is going to drive the
price down and
um particularly for stupid degrees and
that kind of stuff which your kid
wouldn't get Kevin but um but anyway so
all of this to say the landscape is
going to change dramatically on how we
acquire knowledge in the coming 20 years
I'm not saying colleges are going away
are going to become unimportant they're
just going to become less important and
they need to become less important
they've gotten out of control
do you have some sort of guideline as to
how much I should put into it then
because my my hope is to fund a bunch of
it up front so that way it can grow a
lot in the next 18 years yeah I'd
probably throw if you want to get really
aggressive right now though 10 grand in
for a couple years that'll probably put
you up around 120 when it's done if you
never added anything to it and
um talk to your smartvestor Pro run some
calculations on it but if you pop 10
grand in two years in a row or something
you're probably done and then other than
that just go become wealthy and it gives
you other options for what you want to
do with the kit
yeah I I already put 15 000 in so uh
you're saying just drop in another five
and then call it good for the time being
correct yeah yeah and you just got it
all right you can just watch what
happens and see how it unfolds and you
know calculate what 20 would become in
18 years I'm guessing it probably 140 or
something like that and that's going to
be more than enough for whatever and you
can supplement you'll be able to
supplement from there and they may get
scholarships or they may they may decide
to do uh coding and uh for 10 grand was
what it costs right now to get a you
know get a certification in coding and
you can make 100 grand
so why you go spend five hundred
thousand dollars for a 38 000 job
anymore is crazy so you wouldn't
so anyway not not against higher
education I'm just saying that the
landscape is going to change there's too
much Market pressure for it to do
otherwise so good question
congratulations on the new baby it's
exciting yeah that's fun so uh yeah what
are you gonna do with on me as uh at 529
if you're just closing this yet uh I
mean we're we're gonna my parents have
already uh generously offered to start
it not the starter so they're putting
the seed money in there instead of a
normal gift we got too much crap already
around the house for this baby it's
amazing how much stuff a baby can
accumulate with just gifts you need a
minimalist baby so I'm like give us
money instead this girl's gonna be uh
doing it right and again like you're
mentioning we can cash flow the
difference if she happens you know to go
to an expensive school and that's her
dream and we've got the money she's
she's gonna go to that school day
because like you said she's got me
wrapped around her finger already oh
definitely she wants a horse she's
getting a horse Dave
just kidding I have my boundaries she's
a week old yeah
you know how I feel about horses
even George would get up
don't put that evil on me Ricky Bobby oh
yeah I'm just saying you're going to get
yourself in deep deeper stuff here so
hey guys holiday season's coming up I
need to remind you that we're doing
something special uh there's no reason
for you to be in debt why don't you why
don't you not go in debt for Christmas
and start thinking about that now so you
like did that on purpose
because they announced this year
Christmas is in December it shouldn't be
a surprise
so it doesn't sneak up on you tell us
the date yet the exact number I mean I
know I know you got the skeletons out
front of your house right now and the
pumpkins and we're talking about
Christmas but I'm not talking about
Christmas I'm talking about you not
going in debt for Christmas so jump onto
everydollar.com they gave me a slash
everydollar.com Dave I've been wanting a
slash by the time you got your own
website and now it's 65 dollars for
every dollar for an entire year every
dollar premium and that connects to your
bank you can do the free version anytime
you want but this is the premium version
for only 65 bucks you can start right
now and if you're on the every dollar
app you can go to Christmas without that
that puts this hour the Ramsey Show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]